>> Shannon: WE ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
AMERICA’S TOP DIPLOMAT.
SECRETARY OF STATE REX TILLERSON
IS ON A SOUTH AMERICAN TOUR BUT
RUSSIA IS VERY MUCH ON HIS MIND.
TILLERSON TALKED WITH FOX NEWS
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON IN
BOGOTA, COLOMBIA.
GOOD EVENING, RICH.
I UNDERSTAND THE SECRETARY SEES
EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN MEDDLING IN
THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
>> GOOD EVENING, SHANNON.
THEY ARE AND THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
SECRETARY OF STATE AND I SPOKE
AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT RUSSIA, A
CONVERSATION THAT LED TO
RUSSIA’S SUPPORT OF THE ASSAD
REGIME IN SYRIA.
HE SAID RUSSIA NEEDS TO MOVE TO
A DIFFERENT PLACE ON THIS.
THEY CAN DENY IT ALL THEY WANT,
SUPPORT OF THE ASSAD REGIME, AS
IT KILLS ITS OWN CITIZENS BUT HE
SAID FACTS ARE FACTS.
THEY NEED TO GO TO THE SPOT.
THEN WE DISCUSS THE ELECTIONS
AND RUSSIA’S CAPABILITIES TO
INTERFERE IN THE MIDTERMS.
>> THERE’S A LOT OF WAYS THE
RUSSIANS CAN MEDDLE IN THE
ELECTIONS, A LOT OF DIFFERENT
TOOLS THEY CAN USE.
I THINK WHAT WE’VE SEEN, SOME OF
IT WE’VE SEEN THROUGH OUR OWN
SHARING WITH ALLIES AND PARTNERS
OF OURS.
WE ARE SEEING CERTAIN BEHAVIORS,
A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT ELECTIONS
IN THIS HEMISPHERE THIS YEAR,
AND LEADING UP TO THE U.S. IN
2018.
CONTINUE TO SAY TO RUSSIA LOW,
IF YOU THINK WE DON’T SEE WHAT
YOU’RE DOING, WE DO SEE.
YOU NEED TO STOP.
IF YOU DON’T, YOU ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO INVITE CONSEQUENCES.
>> IS THE U.S. BETTER PREPARED
THIS TIME AROUND IN 2016?
STICK A WELCOME I DON’T KNOW I
WOULD SAY WE ARE BETTER
PREPARED.
BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS WILL ADAPT
AS WELL.